Great.
You've installed python.
You're ready to start coding
in your own environment now.
To help you get started we will
be giving you downloadable
files that we call starter code.
And you can use these to follow
along with the instructors.
When you're done with the lesson,
these files will become
handy reference guides.
As you continue on in the Nanodegree.
At key points in your Nanodegree,
you will see pages just like this one.
Each page will have a link for
a download to starter code for
the upcoming section.
You can find that link
under downloadables
at the bottom of this classroom.
In this case I'll click on
this file called variables.
And will open in a new tab.
Then I can simply copy and paste this
text into my text editor of choice.
For me that's Sublime.
Now if you're using Sublime and
a lot of other text editors.
You'll notice that
when you first copy and
paste it,
it doesn't format the text correctly.
But if I save my file, in this case
I'll just call it variables.py.
Dot py refers to Python to tell
the computer it's a python file.
Then I can see that sublime
formats the text correctly.
We recommend that you open
these files in a sublime window
next to your browser,
just like I have here.
And just like how Mike keeps his
documentation open next to his code.
You'll notice that every starter code
file begins with the name of a lesson.
A short summary of
the lesson's concepts,
a link to the first video in the lesson.
And some code that illustrates
the lesson's ideas.
As you continue along in the lesson,
you should add to this file.
However you'd like.
You can add code.
You can add notes.
Just whatever makes sense to you.
Whatever would make a good reference.
Now, let's walk through this next lesson
together to see some best practices for
using starter code.